foreign
this is Professor MDA science and today
I want to build the energy eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions of the hydrogen atom
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics hydrogen is one of the
very few systems for which we can solve
the equations of quantum mechanics
analytically you can find the full
mathematical solution in a companion
video what we will do today is to take
that mathematical solution of the
hydrogen atom and to build the first few
eigenvalues and eigenfunctions to see
what they look like let's go
the hydrogen atom is made of two
particles a proton and an electron we
know from the introductory video on
hydrogen that the center of mass of the
atom moves freely and it is Trivial to
describe it in quantum mechanics
the relevant physics of the system is
encoded by the relative motion of the
proton and the electron and we describe
the hydrogen atom with a one particle
relative hamiltonian that we call H sub
index Rel for relative
the hamiltonian has a kinetic energy
term and a potential energy term
we derived this relative hamiltonian in
the introductory video on the hydrogen
atom and as a reminder mu here is the
reduced mass of the system and is
related to the masses of the proton and
electron by this equation
P here is the relative momentum given by
this expression in terms of the
individual momenta of a proton and
electron and R here is the relative
position given by the distance between
the proton and the electron
for convenience in today's video we will
work in the position representation so
we can rewrite the relative hamiltonian
as equal to the kinetic energy term in
the Precision representation plus the
potential energy term in the position
representation
an important feature of this hamiltonian
is that the potential is a central
potential
and that means that all the results
associated with Central potentials will
apply in the case of hydrogen
this relative hamiltonian is really the
key to understanding the hydrogen atom
using quantum mechanics and in this
video we will calculate a few of its
eigenvalues and eigen functions moving
forward we're going to simplify notation
and we'll just drop the real sub index
and we will simply write H for the
relative hamiltonian but now you know
what we're referring to
okay so the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian takes the usual form where
these are the eigenvalues and these are
the eigenfunctions the full mathematical
solution of this eigenvalue equation is
rather involved but I would say it's
also rather interesting because after
some manipulation you end up with a nice
power series expansion which maybe it's
not something you expected
we've gone through the mathematical
derivation step by step in a companion
video that is linked in the description
so we're not going to repeat it today
but you can check out the link if you
want to know more details
what we will do today is to just take
that solution as a given and we will use
it to calculate eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions
so the first thing we need is a quick
recap of the mathematical solution to
use as a starting point
the first step is to realize that the
hydrogen atom hamiltonian commutes with
orbital angular momentum
this means that the eigenfunctions of
the hamiltonian can be chosen to also be
eigenfunctions of the squared orbital
angular momentum like this
and remember that the quantum number L
can take any non-negative integer value
the eigenfunctions can be chosen to also
be eigenfunctions of the LZ orbital
angular momentum like this
and again remember that for a given l m
l can only take one of these values
separated by integer steps
from these results we can rewrite the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
where we label the eigenfunctions and
eigenvalues with the appropriate quantum
numbers like this
we see that the eigenfunctions depend on
the orbital angular momentum quantum
numbers L and ML and for every
combination LML we have a spectrum of
energy eigen functions labeled by the
additional quantum number k
in principle the energy eigenvalues can
also be labeled by these three quantum
numbers but we find in the videos on
Central potentials that they actually
only depend on K and L but not on ML
thank you
all we've done so far is to Simply
rewrite the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian using the appropriate
quantum numbers for the eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions
that means that we're now ready for a
quick recap of the mathematical solution
the full eigenfunction PSI is given by
the product of a radio part and an
angular part
this angular part here is the same for
any Central potential and is given by
this spherical harmonics which are the
orbital angular momentum eigen functions
and only depend on the quantum numbers L
and ml
we have a whole series of videos on
orbital angular momentum and spherical
harmonics and we will use those results
for building the angular part of the
hydrogen atom eigenfunctions
so moving to the radial part here its
form depends on the precise form of the
radial potential but it is always
labeled by the quantum numbers k and l
figuring out the radial part takes a
rather large number of steps but luckily
for us we've already done that in our
companion mathematical video
so first we rewrite the radial function
in terms of a new function U like this
we then make a change of variables to
rewrite U as a function of a new
variable row row is a ratio of R and the
reduced bore radius
and the reduced ball radius is given by
this expression
okay next by considering the limit of
large row we rewrite a u in terms of yet
another function V like this
in this expression Lambda is defined as
equal to the square root of minus the
eigenvalue over the ionization energy
where the ionization energy is given by
this expression
next we express the function V in a
power series like this where the
exponent s is equal to l Plus 1. the
expansion coefficient CQ is related to
the expansion coefficient C naught by
this rather long expression
and this is true for Q smaller than k
the expansion coefficient CQ vanishes if
Q is larger than or equal to K
these expansion coefficients imply that
the power series is finite
and we then complete the solution by
fixing C naught through normalizing the
wave function
this here is the strategy that we will
follow in this video to build the
eigenfunctions
first we will determine what these C
expansion coefficients are for a given
choice of quantum numbers k and l
we will then use them to construct Phi
then we will build u in terms of the row
variable we'll then go back to the
original coordinate r and once we have
you like this we will construct the
radial function and once we have R we
will finally build the eigenfunctions
with this recipe we can build any eigen
function we want and in this video we
look at a few examples of how to do it
explicitly and we're going to do it step
by step
before we do any of that value we should
clarify that the discussion today
corresponds to the non-relativistic
hydrogen atom so we're not going to
consider topics such as spin fine
structure or hyperfine structure which
have important consequences for the
hydrogen atom eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions but which we're going to
leave for other videos so stay tuned for
those
as we just discussed we need to
normalize the eigenfunctions to fix the
C note expansion coefficient the full
wave function obeys the standard
normalization condition so we could fix
C naught by imposing this condition
however in the videos and Central
potentials we discussed that we can
separately normalize the radial part of
the eigenfunction and the angular part
of the eigenfunction
indeed we have already built the
spherical harmonics such that they are
normalized so in principle we can fix C
naught by using this normalization
condition for the radial part of the
eigenfunction
but in the video on the radial equation
we find that we can equivalently
normalize the U function using this
relation
the original normalization of the radial
function involves the r squared here
but the normalization in terms of the U
function doesn't so this expression is a
general simpler and today we will
normalize the wave function and fix C
naught using this U integral
we need one final piece of recap around
the eigenvaluation
the eigenvalues are in principle labeled
by the indices K and L and given by
miners the ionization energy over K plus
L of squared
remember from the companion mathematical
video that we are only considering bound
states of the hydrogen atom for which
the eigenvalues are negative as the
potential is zero at Infinity
from this expression we see that K and
Del only appear together as a sum here
which suggests that we can define a new
Collective label in
in terms of this new label we can write
the eigenvalues e sub n as equal to
minus the ionization energy Over N
squared
remembering the expression for the
ionization energy that we had earlier we
can rewrite this expression in terms of
the reduced mass and the electron charge
on the numerator and this constant
multiplying the squares of the vacuum
permittivity the reduced plan constant
and the label n
if we use the label n for the
eigenvalues we need to figure out what
are its allowed values
we know that the angular momentum
quantum number L can take non-negative
integer values and we also know from the
companion mathematical video that K can
only take positive integer values
from these we can conclude that n which
is equal to K plus L can only take
positive integer values
but we can actually say more starting
from the fact that n is equal to K plus
l
let's start with the lowest possible n
which is equal to 1. this will
correspond to the lowest energy so to
the ground state of the hydrogen atom
and the only possible values are k
equals one and L equals zero
for the first excited state we have n
equals two we now have two possibilities
either K equals two and L equals zero or
k equals one and L equals one
and both options give the same n and
therefore the same energy
for n equals 3 we now have three options
either K equals three and L equals zero
or k equals two and L equals one all k
equals one and L equals two
and we could of course continue in this
fashion for any n
now if we use n as a quantum number for
the eigenvalues then it would also make
sense to use n as a quantum number for
the eigen functions this means that we
can either label the eigenfunctions with
the quantum numbers k l and ml like this
or with the quantum numbers n l and ml
like this
second option is the most common but we
will make sure that we clarify the
relation between the two throughout this
video
and we're now ready to build the first
few eigenvalues and eigenfunctions of
the hydrogen atom
let's start with the ground state which
is n equals one
if we look at the general expression for
the eigen energies up here we get that
the ground state energy is equal to
minus the ionization energy we can also
explicitly write out the ionization
energy in terms of the reduced mass of
the system and fundamental constants
like this
sticking with the ground state let's now
turn to the eigenfunctions the first
thing to remember is that for n equals
one we've just established that K is one
and that L is zero
to build the eigenfunctions we now have
to follow the recipe that we discussed
earlier where the first step is to
determine the expansion coefficients
using the expression up here
and as k equals 1 and the expansion
coefficients vanish for any Q larger
than or equal to K as shown here then we
can conclude that the only non-zero
expansion coefficient is C naught
to put it another way the ground state
eigenfunctions have a single term in the
power series expansion
the next step is to build V
for the ground state k equals 1 and L
equals zero so that we write V with the
sub indices 1 0.
next as we've just established that all
the expansion coefficients are zero
apart from the first one which
corresponds to Q equals zero then this
expansion up here has a single term
which we can write down explicitly
as s is equal to l plus 1 but L is zero
then the power of rho is simply one this
means that we can get that V sub index 1
0 is equal to C naught times rho
right the next step is to build U
in the ground state this is u 1 0.
inserting the expression for v in
science of this equation we get C naught
times rho times this exponential
now we quickly remind ourselves of the
definition of Lambda and in our case we
have Lambda 1 0 which is equal to this
square root
using the fact that the ground state
energy is equal to minus the ionization
energy we get that Lambda equals one
going back to our expression for U we
get that it is equal to C naught times
rho times the exponential of minus rho
at this point we can go back from row to
R using this relation and we can write
the U function in terms of r as equal to
this
now that we have the U function we can
normalize it to fix C naught rewriting
the normalization condition for the
ground state we get this
using the expression for u 1 0 up here
we end up with this new integral
and we're now going to use a standard
exponential integral which you can look
up in your favorite total of integrals
or actually evaluate it yourself and as
a sequel to this
comparing this exponent with our
exponent up here we can identify p as
equal to 2. and this exponent with this
exponent we get Alpha as equal to 2 over
a naught
for the integral we first get the
absolute value squared of C naught over
a naught squared and we can then use the
standard integral to get 2 factorial
over 2 over a naught or cubed
simplifying we get the absolute value of
squares of C naught multiplying a naught
over four we can then isolate C naught
and get 2 over the square root of a
naught
and by the way I have made a phase
Choice such that we end up with a real
positive constant
with this result we can rewrite U1 0 as
equal to this prefactor times R times
the exponential
okay we are almost done the next step is
to go to the original radial function in
the ground state this is r 1 0 inserting
the expression for U inside this
equation we get the pre-factor times the
exponential
finally the full eigenfunction is given
by the product of the radial function
and the corresponding spherical harmonic
in our case as L equals zero then ml
only has one possible value which is
also zero
using the results from the video on
spherical harmonics y 0 0 is equal to 1
over the square root of 4 pi
we can insert this expression for the
spherical harmonic all the way up here
and this expression we just found for
the radial function into this term
with this we get the ground state wave
function using the klml quantum numbers
and we end up with the ground state wave
function of the hydrogen atom as equal
to this prefactor times this exponential
if we instead use the nlml notation in
this particular case the ground state is
also labeled as psi100 and of course
it's given by the same expression
it is great to have this mathematical
expression for the gram state
eigenfunction but it would be helpful to
also visualize it unfortunately we
cannot fully visualize it because it
depends on three coordinates which means
that we would need a four-dimensional
space to draw it fully and what we will
do instead is to separately visualize
the radial part and the angular part
this is a depiction of the gram State
wave function of the hydrogen atom the
radial part on the left shows that the
eigenfunction decreases exponentially as
we move away from the origin of the
potential the angular part on the right
right here is an eigen state of orbital
angular momentum and in this particular
case it is the y 0 0 spherical harmonic
which is simply a constant
if you need a refresher on how to draw
spherical harmonics check out the
corresponding video we've linked it in
the description in general they depend
on the angular variables Theta and Phi
so we can draw them on the unit sphere
and we use a red white blue color
gradient scale with red representing
positive white is zero and blue is
negative
in this case we get a uniform red sphere
because the Y 0 0 spherical harmonic is
a positive constant
overall the ground stage eigenfunction
of hydrogen takes its maximum value at
the origin of the potential and then
decays away from the origin and does so
isotropically
the ground state of the hydrogen atom
has an iconic place in physics and in
chemistry and we have a video
exclusively dedicated to exploring in
more depth the physical meaning of this
ground state eigenfunction so I
encourage you to follow the link in the
description to check it out
but for now let's go on and construct
some excited state eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions
let's now move to the first excited
state
the procedure is analogous to what we
just did for the ground state so we're
going to go quicker through the
calculations but I encourage you to fill
in the gaps
let's start again with the eigenvalues
and let's consider n equals two
the energy E2 of the first excited state
is equal to minus the ionization energy
over four
let's now turn to the eigenfunctions
remembering that for n equals 2 we have
two possibilities we can have k equals 2
and L equals zero or we can have k
equals 1 and L equals one
so let's first focus on this top case
from the expression CQ at the top we see
that the non-zero expansion coefficients
are those for which Q is smaller than k
as we have k equals 2 we can conclude
that we have two non-zero expansion
coefficients C naught and C1
using the expression in the first line
at the top here we can plug in the
values Q equals one k equals two and L
equals zero to write C1 as equal to this
long expression
and it trivially evaluates two minus C
naught over two
so the power Series has two non-zero
expansion coefficients C naught here and
C1 here which we can write in terms of C
naught like this
the next step is to build V
remembering that we're working with this
combination of K and L we have V two
zero we've just established that we have
two terms in the power series one
corresponding to Q equals zero and one
corresponding to Q equals one
as s is equal to l plus 1 and L is zero
we can conclude that s equals one
and we can then rewrite Phi as the sum
over these two terms
finally remember that we've just
established that C1 is equal to minus C
naught over two so taking C naught as a
common factor here we end up with this
expression in summary the function V 2 0
takes this form
the next step is to build U to zero we
can insert this expression we just found
for V 2 0 into this expression and get
this polynomial term times the
exponential
for the exponential we need to determine
Lambda which remember is given by this
expression
in our case we have Lambda 2 0 which is
equal to this square root
using the fact that the energy is equal
to minus the ionization energy divided
by four we get that Lambda equals
one-half
and this implies that U is equal to C
naught times this polynomial in row
times this exponential of minus rho over
2.
at this point we can go back from row to
R using this relation and we can write
for you function in terms of r as equal
to this
we again determine C naught by
normalizing the function U and we have
this normalization integral inserting
the expression for u 2 0 into the
normalization condition we first get the
absolute value squared of C naught and
then the integral has three terms in the
integrand arising from the square of the
polynomial featuring in U to 0.
feel free to Port here to cross check
this step
each of the terms in the integrand is a
power of R times an exponential so we
can again use the same standard
exponential integral to evaluate each
term which remember is given by this
expression
now I'm going to skip a few
manipulations which I encourage you to
fill in and this is what we get
rearranging we get that c naught is
equal to 1 over square root of 2A naught
where I have again made a phase Choice
such that we end up with a real positive
constant
with this result we can rewrite U to 0
as equal to this prefactor times this
polynomial in r
times the exponential
the next step is to go to the original
radial function which in our case is R
to zero inserting the expression for U
inside this equation we get this
prefactor times this polynomial times
this exponential
finally the four ligand function is
given by the product of the radial
function and the corresponding spherical
harmonic
as l equals 0 we again have ml equals
zero and this spherical harmonic is
again y 0 0 and equal to one over the
square root of 4 pi
so if we use the KL and L notation the
overall eigenfunction of this first
excited stage is given by this
expression
using the nlm notation in this
particular case we also have PSI 2 0 0
for the first excited state
and of course we have the same explicit
expression
we will come back to this eigen function
to visualize it in a moment but before
we do that let's construct the other
possible first excited States
going back to the starting point of the
first excited state eigenfunctions which
remember are given by n equals two we're
now going to focus on this second
possible combination of K and L as k
equals 1 then from this condition on Q
here we can conclude that all expansion
coefficients apart from C naught vanish
the next step is to build V
remembering that we are working with
this combination of K and L we have v11
we've just established that we have a
single term in the power series The One
corresponding to key equals zero so we
get to this single term
as s is equal to l plus one we get this
and as L is equal to one we can rewrite
V like this
overall v11 is equal to C naught times
rho squared
the next step is to build to u11 so
inserting this expression we just got
for V into this equation we get C naught
rho squared times this exponential
we are still working with the first
excited state so Lambda 1 1 is the same
that we got earlier for Lambda 2 0 which
is equal to one half and that implies
that U is equal to C naught times rho
squared times the exponential of minus
rho over 2.
and we can now go back from row to R
using this relation and we can write the
U function in terms of r as equal to
this
we now move to normalizing the function
U to determine C naught
inserting the expression we have for you
into the normalization integral we get
this integral
we can use the same standard exponential
integral that we've been using
throughout and skipping a few steps we
end up with this
rearranging we get that c naught is
equal to 1 over square root of 24 a
naught
where as usual we choose a face such
that we end up with a real positive
constant and this all means that we can
rewrite u11 as equal to this prefactor
times this term proportional to r
squared times the exponential
the next step is to go to the original
radial function which in our case is R11
inserting the expression for you inside
this equation we get the prefactor times
the term proportional to R times the
exponential
finally the full eigenfunction is given
by the product of the radial function
and the corresponding spherical harmonic
as l equals 1 then ml has three possible
values minus one zero and one using the
results from the video on spherical
harmonics we have that y 1 minus 1 is
equal to this expression
why one zero is equal to this expression
and Y 1 1 is equal to this other
expression
this leads to three distinct
eigenfunctions and we are going to start
with the klml labels as shown up here
the first one is PSI 1 1 minus 1 and is
given by this combined prefactor the r
dependent terms and the angular
dependent terms
the second one is psi110 and is given by
this combined prefactor the r dependent
terms and the angular term
and the third is site 111 given by this
other combined three Factor the r
dependent terms and the angular terms
using the nlm notation these three
eigenfunctions are labeled as PSI 2 1
minus one PSI two one zero
and psi211
right so we can now bring together all
the results for the first excited state
and we end up with four distinct
eigenfunctions
using the nlm notation the first
eigenfunction corresponds to the 2 0 0
and is PSI two zero zero it is equal to
this radial function and this angular
function and explicitly written like
this
the next three eigenfunctions correspond
to quantum numbers 2 1 minus one giving
PSI 2 1 minus one two one zero giving
PSI 2 1 0 and 2 1 1 giving PSI two one
one they all have the same radial part
here here and here
the angular Parts however differ with
the Y one minus one spherical harmonic
for the first one the Y one zero
spherical harmonic for the second one
and the Y one one spherical harmonic for
the third one
explicitly we get this for PSI two one
minus one
this for PSI two one zero
and this pasai two one one
these results show that the radial
function is the same for a given angular
momentum L quantum number but different
between different values of L with L
equals zero here and L equals one and
these three cases here here and here
overall the first excited state of the
hydrogen atom is therefore fourfold
degenerate
let's now plot the fast excited to date
eigenfunctions
first of all I'm showing the radial
parts and I am using the NL ml notation
so I hope that this is not too confusing
a bit to the original derivations where
we were using the klml notation
the figure on the left corresponds to
the L equals zero radial function like
the ground stage radial function it has
a positive value at the origin and then
decays away from it
however unlike the ground state radial
function this radial function has a node
where it vanishes and then becomes
negative
finally it approaches zero again from
Below
the figure on the right corresponds to
the L equals one radial function which
remember corresponds to three distinct
eigenfunctions one for each possible ml
value it is zero at the origin grows to
a maximum value and then decreases
towards zero as we move away from the
origin
bringing in the angular parts we start
with PSI 2 0 0 which like the ground
state is isotropic
for PSI 2 1 minus 1 we get these radial
and angular parts
and for ease of visualization we can
make the diagram of the spherical
harmonic rotate like this
the Y one minus one stroke harmonic is a
complex function and we are plotting
both it's real and it's imaginary parts
and again if you need a refresher about
how we plot historical harmonics you can
check out the corresponding video Linked
In the description
for psi210 we get these radial and
angular parts and in this case the
spherical harmonic is a real function
that is spherically symmetric
for psi211 we get these radial and
angular parts and we can again make the
Y one one struggle harmonic rotate
we could repeat the same exercise for
any other eigenfunction but now that
you've seen how it works for the ground
state and first excited state you will
be able to calculate the eigenfunctions
for any other state yourself
to encourage you to explore this further
I will finish the video by showing the
results for the second excited state
corresponding to n equals 3. the energy
of the second excited state is equal to
minus the ionization energy over nine
and we've seen earlier in the video that
there are now three possible choices of
K and L that give n equals three
first possibility is k equals 3 and L
equals zero this corresponds to n equals
three and L equals zero this leads to a
single eigenfunction which in the NL ml
notation is PSI three zero zero
the second possibility is k equals two
and L equals one
or equivalently n equals three and L
equals one
we have three eigenfunctions which again
using nlml notation are PSI three one
minus one PSI three one zero and PSI 311
and the third possibility is k equals
one and a equals two or n equals three
and Del equals two
and this leads to five eigenfunctions
which in nlml notation are PSI three two
minus two side three two minus 1 psi
three two zero PSI three two one and PSI
three two two
I'm now showing the plots of the radial
functions associated with the second
excited state
the plot at the top corresponds to the
case when l equals zero in this case the
series solution has three terms leading
to this expression for the radial
function
the radio function starts as a positive
value and decays away as we move away
from the origin with two notes here and
here
this radial function corresponds to a
single eigenfunction associated with the
l equals zero spherical harmonic
the figure in the middle corresponds to
the case when l equals one in this case
the series solution has two terms
leading to this radial function the
radial function starts at zero then
grows to a maximum then decreases
crosses zero reaches a minimum and then
approaches zero From Below as we move
away from the origin
this radial function corresponds to
three distinct eigenfunctions whose
angular part is given by the L equals
one spherical harmonics
to figure at the bottom corresponds to
the case when l equals two
in this case the series solution has a
single term that leads to this
expression the radial function starts at
zero grows to a maximum and decreases to
zero as we move away from the origin
this radio function corresponds to five
distinct eigenfunctions whose angular
part is given by the L equals two
spherical harmonics
overall these results indicate that the
second excited state is nine-fold
degenerate
today we have explicitly built and
visualized the energy eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions of hydrogen to learn more
about both I would encourage you to
check out the subsequent videos in our
series on the hydrogen atom these videos
will include a detailed study of the
ground state as well as the emission
spectrum of the hydrogen atom and as
always if you liked the video please
subscribe
foreign